what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the mcu and today we
actually have some really really
interesting spider-man no way home news
actually yesterday and today we have
some news but i was in la yesterday for
the eternals and now we're back home and
now
kevin feige has spoken up about the
coordination between marvel and sony
when it came down to that venom let
there be carnage post credits scene then
today tom hardy posted something to
instagram and then took it down in true
tom hardy fashion he's always doing that
he's always giving us those cryptic
photos and then taking them down and
then if you kind of put all of this
together we actually have found out that
we've actually kind of seen no way home
footage that we really weren't aware of
at the time if you've seen that venom
let there be carnage post credit scene
and i'm going to break this all down in
this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you stay up to date on all
things happening with spiderman netway
home and in the mcu and also we are
doing a giveaway a spider-man giveaway
this was provided by sidekick central
check them out on instagram all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to me and
subscribe to my other channel that chris
runs cosmic culture now if you have seen
venom let there be carnage then you have
most certainly seen its post credit
scene i mean if you've been on the
internet and any type of social media
you've probably heard what happened in
the post-credits scene and if you
haven't by now and you actually want to
see it before hearing about it here is
your official spoiler alert if you're
still here you know that the venom let
there be carnage scene showed us a few
very important things one venom is now
in the mcu he was transported to the
same universe that all of our beloved
characters exist in including tom
holland spider-man right now it's kind
of unclear on whether or not the whole
entire sony venom universe is put into
the mcu or just venom and eddie brock
but that's something we'll have to wait
and see about another thing that we saw
obviously was spider-man on the screen
and venom looking the screen which was
awesome and very true venom fashion but
something that you may not have noticed
about the scene is that this is actually
entirely new footage that we have not
seen before i re-watched the
post-credits scene for spider-man no way
home and this is not the post-credits
scene footage in the post-credits scene
peter parker has his mask on the entire
time we only see spider-man not peter
parker but in the venom let there be
carnage post-credit scene we actually
see peter parker and unless sony kind of
just did what they want and added their
own footage in here which i really doubt
they did this is probably actual footage
from spider-man no way home we have j
jonah jameson on the screen much like we
saw at the post credit scene of
spider-man no way home and the footage
of him seems to be news cameras from
helicopters circling around him so this
is most likely the beginning of
spider-man no way home or another point
in spider-man no way home where he's
being chased why would he take his mask
off i'm not really sure that kind of
gives it all away and pretty much says
hey everybody look yeah it's me peter
parker i'm spider-man so not really sure
about that one it makes me think that
this maybe could be mock footage that
disney allowed sony to use but might not
actually be in the film however
considering what kevin feige recently
said i do believe it's actual footage in
a recent interview with the
hollywoodreporter.com
they asked kevin feige about venom's
post credit scene and a little bit of
what it took to make it happen they
asked how the scene came together and
here's what kevin feige said there was a
lot of coordination and if you don't
know all the coordination yet i'm not
going to be the one to tell you but yes
between sony and marvel and the venom
team and the no way home team we worked
together on it now this is actually a
pretty big statement because if this was
just a sony thing that would mean a lot
less than it would be if kevin feige and
marvel studios was working on it with
them which they were this leads me to
believe that what we saw on the venom
post credits scene on the tv was actual
footage from spiderman no way home but
the fact that kevin feige said that they
had to work with sony and everything was
coordinated means a lot more we
obviously know that venom is now in the
mcu but the biggest question is when and
really the question is is he actually
going to be in spider-man no way home
and this question actually gets even
bigger if you consider the fact that tom
hardy posted a venom and spider-man
photo today on his instagram but then
deleted it now for those of you who may
not know tom hardy is infamous for doing
this he did it before with a photo of
venom basically eating spiderman where
he put it to instagram and then took it
down but of course you know fans we're
on top of it and we screenshot things
cause we know that tom hardy might take
things down plus we want to post on the
internet and you know make youtube
videos about it but tom hardy does it
again today posting a picture of venom
and spider-man another picture of venom
attempting to eat spider-man with the
caption happy holidays and halloween
snacks could the big coordination
between sony and marvel go past the
post-credits scene obviously it does
because venom is now in the mcu but does
that mean he is going to be in no way
home is that why there was so much
coordination involved and the obvious
two answers here are one yes he is going
to be in no way home in some shape or
form now i personally don't really want
him to be a villain in no way home
because i don't really think that it
would make too much sense would i like
venom and eddie brock to be in the film
yes but it wouldn't make sense if they
just went off and fought spider-man i
want a lot more character development
between the two of them and story
building before that actually happens i
will say something that could happen
that i would like is that all of a
sudden eddie brock finds himself in this
universe and the only thing he really
recognizes is the daily bugle since in
his universe he worked for the daily
bugle and the new one in the mcu he
could go and try to find the daily bugle
to see if he knows anybody from there he
could kind of get situated with his
whole new universe thing then get a job
at thedailybugle.net and that's where
jjj could plant all of these ideas that
spider-man is a menace inside of his
head then venom could get jealous and
this could start kind of all of the bad
blood between them which eventually
would lead them to face off against each
other eventually though because that
would make spider-man noway home way too
focused on this side story so i don't
think it should be in no way home but
obviously the second option which is
what i've been guessing for a while now
is the spider-man know a home
post-credits scene or at least one of
them could have venom in it to me i
think that would be a coordination that
kevin feige could be talking about here
they coordinated between the two of them
for their post-credit scenes sony for
venom let there be carnage for their
post-credit scene will show venom
entering the mcu and show spider-man on
screen then marvel studios and disney
for no way home will show a post-credits
scene of some type of interaction with
venom and possibly spider-man in the mcu
and this is probably the best way to do
it considering how big spider-man
knowing home is going to be there's
already a lot going on we already have
six villains coming for the sinister six
and hopefully toby maguire and andrew
garfield are coming as well plus not to
mention all of the stuff happening in
peter parker's life with mj with ned
with aunt may there's just so much going
on to add just another element to this
movie even though i really really want
it to happen but again venom and
spider-man meeting is such a big thing
you just can't have it happen and force
it to happen quickly it needs to build
but in kevin feige we trust that guy
knows what he's doing and i'm sure
everything and spider-man no way home is
going to be absolutely fantastic but i
want to know do you think venom is going
to be making his mcu debut in spider-man
no way home in the actual movie or do
you think he's going to do it in the
post-credits scene let me know what you
think in the comments down below and of
course don't forget to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things spiderman no
way home don't forget to like the video
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you